Who was behind the coup in Turkey? At this
point, there's three main conspiracies which
are out there. President Erdogan is blaming
Fethullah Gulen, a former ally turned rival
who's an Islamic cleric who's an exile in
Pennsylvania. He wants him extradited. He
says that his followers in the police force
in the military were behind this attempt to
oust his democratically elected government.
However, the Turkish military has traditionally
been the domain of the Kemalists, the followers
of Mustafa Kemal Ataturk, the founder of modern
Turkey. They're staunch secularists; they
hate Fethullah Gulen. And now that the Erdogan
government has also accused the former head
of the air force, General Ozturk, it seems
unlikely that he would ever be a Gulen-ist.
The other possibility, of course, is that
Erdogan's followers himself staged this as
a sort of Reichstag fire. One of the generals
arrested, Mehmet Disli, is actually the brother
of the AKP's vice president. We're not going
to know for a long time who was behind this.
So who was behind the coup? Will we ever know?
Let us know in the comments below and let
us know any other topics you’d like AEI
scholars to cover in 60 Seconds.